Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P Here is an interesting
voicemail about HIPA vaccines and the Roe
v Wade decision. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I was just thinking
this morning, why is it that when it comes to
vaccinations, the Republicans are worried about
their hip? Yes, but when it comes to abortions,
that's everybody's business.
Speaker 1: Okay. So I like the call in. In truth,
none of this really is about hip hop. Remember
that HIPA is about privacy regulations that govern
medical providers, medical providers. It doesn't
apply to legislators or journalists or whatever
anyway. But the point here is a good one, which
is with something that relates to communicable
and contagious disease, which you could argue, I
am affected by the person next to me. They say,
Oh, you can't even ask about vaccine status,
never mind require a vaccine. And yet here,
when it comes to something that's non-communicable
and is a personal decision, they seem to not care
whatsoever about the ability of an individual to
make the medical decision that's best for them
with their doctors and the Council of Medical
Professionals. That is absolutely a double
standard and I'm glad that it is being pointed
out. But good luck convincing these people about
anything. They are. They're gone. To quote
Alex Jones, we have a bonus show. We do it
every day. The bonus show is an additional show
that we do for our members. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com and get instant access to the
bonus show. You can also use the coupon code Obama
to get a discount Obama Now today's bonus show we
will talk about. Remember all those issues with
the unruly airline passengers in the immediate
aftermath, I guess we would say, of the pandemic,
those unruly passenger problems have plummeted to
a multi-year low. We'll talk about why and what's
going on. Secondly, Intuit, which is the company
that makes TurboTax is going to have to pay
a 140 plus million dollar settlement
over their supposedly free TurboTax,
which isn't really free. I have a lot to say
about that, and we're going to talk about it.
And thirdly, a judge has ruled that an Arizona
prisoner is psychologically fit to be executed.
How backwards is this death penalty, my friends?
How backwards is this death penalty? All of those
stories and more we will discuss on today's
bonus show. Sign up at join pacman dot com get
access. Otherwise I'll see you back tomorrow.
Unidentified: On the Friday show.